et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christopher chanterai vice président de
l'association british community
committee aux france christopher
chanterai bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors boris johnson a prononcé son
premier discours depuis la sortie du
royaume uni il a soigneusement évité le
mot briques site
qu'est ce que cela révèle celui ça fait
partie de la politique fada sa politique
c'est le brésil
là le public britannique doit comprendre
que le breakbeat c'était un sujet passé
on entre dans une nouvelle ère c'est
fait donc on entre en quelques heures en
quelque sort il a raison on va négocier
les rapports futurs donc la sortie est
fait on n'en parle plus dans les
rapports futurs justement la volonté de
moritz one sonne c'est de revenir un
champion du libre-échange reprendre le
contrôle de sa politique commerciale
est ce qu'il pourra effectivement selon
vous re négocier tout azimuts comme il
le souhaite
ben je pense qu'il pourra négocier en
parallèle avec différents pays mais est
ce que savait ce que le résultat sera
une réussite pour le paie pour le pays
nous nous qui représentons les citoyens
britanniques en france et dans un sens
plus large puccini est une autre
association qui représente les intérêts
des britanniques établis dans les pays
de l'union à 27 nous nous espérons
pouvoir influencer ces négociations pour
que les droits qu'on a perdue avec
l'accord du 31 janvier soit rétabli donc
certains droits qu on a perdu parce que
quel droit très concrètement là il ya
notamment tout ce qui concerne les
étudiants et le prix de la scolarité
dans les universités
britannique le britannique qui réside
dans les pays en dehors du royaume uni
ii aux parents les familles ne soient
pas payés au tarif étrangers qui est le
double du tarif des domestiques jusqu'à
maintenant c'était le t rex deux
domestiques
par ailleurs et il ya le problème de la
de droit que du droit qu'on a perdu de
s'établir dans un autre pays membre de
l'union
la une les britanniques qui sont établis
dans les pays de l'union à 27 risque de
se voir afin de ne pas pouvoir
progresser professionnellement
si pour les employeurs pour les clients
en ce qui concerne les libéraux c'est
plus difficile de s'établir dans un
autre pays j'ai des collègues qui
partent qu'ils changent de pays tous les
2-3 ans là ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour ces gens là un sujet qui
sera au coeur donc une négociation dans
entendu michel barnier il ya quelques
instants rappelé avec fermeté que
l'accès du royaume uni au marché
européen devra respecter un certain
nombre de règles
de son côté me boris johnson rejette un
alignement sur l'union européenne
chacun affiche donc ses jo objectif
d'après 10 négociations à venir un parc
oui c'est le premier jour un don chacun
affiche ses objectifs qui sont assez
assez loin les uns des autres
c'est vrai que et tous les deux une
chance heures et monsieur barnier ce
qu'ils disent c'est exactement ce à quoi
on s'attend donc on verra bien dans
l'est dans les prochains mois en tout
cas selon vous est-ce que ça va pouvoir
les positions des uns et des autres vont
pouvoir s'assouplir ils devront ça ne
servirait à rien de se regarder en
chiens de faïence et de ne pas assouplir
sa position événements tristes hier à
londres l'attaqué revendiquée par l'état
islamique cela rappelle également la
question de la sécurité qui reste au
premier plan
quel compromis pour vous devront être
trouvés sur ce sujet de la sécurité
là il faut pas qu'ils aient des conduits
là il faut qu'il ait un accord solide
parce que c'est vrai que
un des problèmes qui qui se parmi les
problèmes qui surviennent à la suite de
la sortie du rmi il ya c'est ce cette
question de la coopération en matière
sécuritaire et là il faut vraiment
prendre que les gaulois est muni et les
pays-bas et l'union européenne soit bien
soudée sur ces questions il y avait
également on l'a vu dans le sujet la
question de la pêche
oui sus le royaume-uni est en position
de force sur cette question là comment
l'europe devra négocier selon vous cette
cette question de la pêche sur la
question de la pêche
il faut pas vous rappeler que la grand
partie d'eads et de la pêche a péché par
les britanniques dans les mers
britannique est exporté vers l'union sda
la france notamment
mais d'autres pays de l'union donc
magique la majorité de la tâche en est
extrait en 4/5 son ex passée donc il
faut faire attention parce que c'est
bien beau de dire oui on a maîtrisé nous
et aux territoriales mais il faut
pouvoir vendre sa production sa pêche ou
continue à vendre donc sans droits de
douane si possible là il ya beaucoup de
contradictions tendance que dit monsieur
johnson s'est pas cette incohérence et
monsieur barnier a raison de parler de
cohérence il dit ils retrouveront à ce
que c'est pas le moment pour le royaume
uni de montrer un peu ses points forts
juillet le mans et bure peser dans les
négociations ou début de la négociation
bien sûr chacun montre ses muscles
l'europe en tout cas est-ce que selon
vous il est en position de force
en tout cas pour mieux négocier oui je
pense parce que c'est tout de même ça
reste le bloc des changes de libre
échange le plus grand du monde c'est
beaucoup plus important que le marché
britannique
il faut pas se leurrer aussi on sait que
le système européen le marché unique
mise en place
l'initiative en grand partie des
britanniques et ya plus d'un an
c'était ça on a besoin de ça pour les
échanges fluides et pour la continuité
de la fabrication de produits
industriels en flux tendu où seule ville
de construction d'avions et beaucoup
d'autres activités
la population britannique plus
particulièrement les populations les
plus populaires les plus pauvres selon
vous quel impact cette sortie du royaume
uni de l'union européenne pourrait avoir
sur ces populations à ce qu elles vont
ressentir ce qu'il va y avoir des effets
dans leur quotidien ira il y aurait fait
oui il y aura des effets vous savez que
dans tous les cas de figure les
instituts économiques à commencer par le
fonds monétaire international et
d'autres d'autres institutions prévoient
une baisse de la du produit national
peut donc dans tous les cas je crois que
ça a été dit ou parlement britannique
cet après midi on dit donc parler de -6
7% dans un document gouvernemental là
qui date de 2018 - 6,7 pour cent dans le
cas d'un accord type canada et dans le
cas d'un accord type australien c'est à
dire sans son 110 l'instant
où tout vous terme au mc ou conditions
omc
ce serait moins 9,3 pour cent voilà ce
que ceux ci a pas d'accord on le
rappelle c'est go mc 1 qui qui qui
arbitre oui oui ce serait dans les
conditions de l'om c'est donc sans sans
accord spécial du tout est là donc c'est
des baisses de 2 pnb qui sont
considérables il y a donc les accords
avec l'union européenne avec les états
unis comment est ce que va se comporter
le royaume uni selon vous america first
on a bien entendu dans la bouche de
monsieur tron je pense que ça va être
quand même difficile il ya il compte
beaucoup
johnson sur les états unis justement
pour surmonter ce qui compte beaucoup
oui oui et on entend des il ya des
choses qui sont dites qu'ils sont censés
nous encourager
vers un changement des modes de
consommation donc le poulet qui il avait
au chlore vous cette année mais il ya
d'autres considérations qui qu'on n'a
pas entendu par exemple le ski on si on
compare les prix des décès d'henri la
viande de la longue houle est d'un seul
d'un supermarché moyen américain avec
les prix d'un supermarché moyens
britannique
on voit que c'est plus cher aux états
unis donc un accord commercial n'est
jamais qu'un qu'une autorisation à
vendre ce n'est pas une le consommateur
n'est pas forcé d'acheter comme les les
produits pharmaceutiques
également on n'est pas le service
national de santé qui est un grand
acheteur de produits pharmaceutiques
n'est pas obligé ne pas pas obligé
d'acheter mais les pros du lait les
producteurs ont le droit aurait le droit
de proposer leurs produits mais il faut
encore que le prix soit attractif pour
conclure en amour onze mois de
négociations trop court selon vous à
passer c'est très court oui
et puis c'est même pas 11 mois parce que
déjà février il ya des discussions entre
les 27 du mandat dont il faut mettre les
27 pays ensemble au même diapason et
puis à l'été il y assez rythmée par les
réunions du conseil européen donc c'est
octobre il faut pratiquement avoir
terminé en octobre mars à octobre
six mois c'est pas merci beaucoup
intrigué à christopher centre et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation des
réactionnaires tesfran je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président de
l'association british community
committee of france